I tell the team we need this done by
3:00 p.m. they say got it we'll have it
done by 3:00 p.m. but they don't deliver
on time and tell me well we didn't know
we needed it done by 3:00 p.m. how do I
take ownership of this mm-hmm yeah this
is it this seems like a tough question
right but it's actually not that type of
a question because what you think is a
cool date they said they're done then
they didn't get it done then how can
that be my fault and well maybe that's
not how the question is meant but that's
the way I'm interpreting it for the
purpose of this answer sure because
maybe you just meant like hey how do I
take ownership of this and if that's the
way you meant it fine the answer is the
same actually so what happens is if that
happens with what happens is if that
happens with your team then you take
ownership of it by recognizing that you
did not communicate effectively because
if your team isn't doing what it is you
need them to do that is actually your
fault as the team leader they either
didn't understand how important it was
of it didn't understand how solid that
deadline was or they didn't understand
that when you said this thing needs to
be completed by three o'clock that you
meant completed by three o'clock maybe
it's cuz you usually say hey we need
this done tomorrow at 2:00 and you give
him slack and they just kind of take
advantage of it bla bla bla then you
know if you want to take ownership of it
maybe you didn't follow up enough right
maybe you trusted them too much whose
fault is it if he trusted him so much
that you just let him you showed up at
2:59 is it done
well no we didn't think it was due like
we didn't know you needed it action so
whose fault is that it's your fault you
trusted him too much maybe you gave them
too much leeway right maybe you give him
too much lately too much decentralized
command economy leadership maybe you
went too far with decentralized command
you said hey get this done by three
o'clock figure however you want to do it
I'll be back at 2:59
and you roll out and it's not done so
what do you do you come back at three
o'clock it's not done it is your fault
do you take ownership of it you say to
your team look hey okay so no how how do
you take ownership of it cool you fix
the problem how do you fix the problem
in this case well guess what next time I
tell you something's not done at three
o'clock I'm gonna check in with you I'm
gonna check in with you a few times
here's the progress that we want
make I want you to be here by this point
I want you be here by this point I
should be here that by this point and
that puts us on track to finish well
ahead of three o'clock mmm
so let's make it happen are you gonna
micromanage a little bit more yes you
are they missed a deadline you're not
allowed to miss deadlines yeah
not allowed to miss deadlines do i
micromanage you echo Charles no have you
ever missed a deadline no well there's
been some podcast that didn't come out
on time right well yeah I guess the
depends on which means yeah I guess but
yeah yeah there's been some podcast that
didn't come out on time yes and I would
send you a text like hey just wondering
if you knew about a podcast that was you
know supposed to come out five hours ago
that happened one time
well no 2:10 I think it's have the two
times yeah yeah one of them yeah so you
don't warrant micromanagement yeah cuz
you we've done a hundred and forty-seven
podcasts and you've had two that weren't
out on time do I need to micromanage you
know I don't don't need to cuz we're all
good the podcast ke occasionally the
times that they didn't come out one of
them was like straight up operator error
where you were like I didn't press the
button publish or something really lame
like that yes the other time was like
major technical difficulty we got a
problem it's gonna be a couple days yeah
then there was another time what was the
other time when we went to Maine the
first last year and what happened we
just got there on the night that I was
supposed to publish it my mind is just
distracted by the new I had lost my
camera it is a crazy time for everybody
and you know the next morning you so you
know graciously posted a picture of me
sleeping on the plane publish a podcast
publicly which is completely she by the
way
but hey everyone having fun yeah yeah it
was it was actually completely warranted
because it really captured like what it
felt like I just totally spaced it out
so my point is you get stuff done on
time you have a good track record
there's no need for micromanagement if
you were if you were hitting a lower
number you know if every you know once
every once a month it wasn't on time you
be hearing about it all the time for me
like hey we good tomorrow we good I'd be
checking in with you until you got so
mad
at me following up with you you would
just be like hey I got this and you
would never miss it again because you
didn't want to be bothered so for this
one again it's important to remember
that with the idea of extreme ownership
it's not just like oh well I'll say this
is my fault
no when you're in charge of a team and
something goes wrong it actually is your
fault it actually is your fault and
that's all there is to it maybe there's
some people you need to fire because
they are though they're at fault for
this mistake happening and you've let it
gone too long and you didn't get rid of
them that's your fault yeah but it
actually is your fault how do you take
owner how do you take ownership of it
you fix the problem
maybe you got a in this particular case
maybe you gotta step up the
micromanagement that's that's the way it
works yeah make sense also to the well
and I'm speaking from a perspective of
someone who could very well easily space
out this project by 3:00 p.m. by the way
that's me that's potentially me but this
is this is when it can't happen where
let's say I get a list of like two three
things whatever I got to do right now
hey we you know we want this or whatever
and then let's say it's not necessarily
by 3 p.m. let's say it's like by next
week Friday so I thought we can have to
do these three things and then the next
day there's like another list of two
things and the next day after that one
thing says hey you know what this is the
priority three days later after Lisbon
establish hey this is a priority get
this done first then you want one more
thing right so this thing that I said
yeah got it I'll have it done by Friday
kind of thing sort of gets shuffled and
forgotten
you know like forgotten so maybe I
didn't organize it or and say this is
putting yourself on report yeah are you
saying that you need to make a list are
you saying you need to write things down
yes people that miss things you know you
do you write them down yeah I used to
make little boxes I'll show you some of
the checklist you come to my house I'll
show you checklist I used to make there
they were psycho OCD little checklist
little boxes next to like I would be
going on a trip I would make a little
box socks t-shirts yeah everything every
single thing I was taking I would have
on a list I still got those I got
deployments from the 90s of what I took
on deployment as
right there little boxes little boxes in
the 90s they were written down on paper
and then in the 2000s I got that
computer and I print those things out
note so hey people have problems if you
personally are telling me that you have
a problem that you're gonna write
something down yes oh yeah and obviously
you know mean you're different those
kind of notes but what I'm saying is
yeah like that could be your methodology
of your micro quote/unquote micro
management style for things like this
just make sure they got it kind of thing
like if you're for Strings I'm thinking
in fact there could you canyou can give
lists I normally wouldn't have to do
this mm-hmm but sometimes there's been a
couple times on Mike life and career
where I'd have to give people a less
like hey boxes form like hey here's what
you gotta get done today yeah make sure
we understand each other I would only do
that if they drop the ball a couple
times yeah like oh they didn't get this
done they didn't get that done okay
guess what I need to write it down and
make sure it happens yeah so yeah and
again it's not like I'm like I'm not
saying it's not my fault because you
give me too much I'm not saying that I'm
saying like not everyone me I'm talking
on me not everyone's as organized as
maybe you you know so they're gonna need
some micromanagement in this particular
way you know me because maybe that's it
I mean I think the tone here the
question
it could be me totally gonna be me
mystery yeah but it kind of seems like
hey they said they got it and they
didn't get it what more do you want from
me kind of thing you know I think that's
a good way of putting it and I just gave
the list of what more you can do yeah
exactly you can spell it out for me you
can micromanage you can check and do
check-ins with them do all those things
yeah